as his life partner of 46 years is there
a part of you that is worried about his
age and health can he do it he can do it
and I see Joe every day I see him out
you know traveling around this country I
see his Vigor I see his energy I see his
passion every single day
no I don't even know why I don't I mean
listen man I get it because you know
we're stuck with what we got right like
I think that the Republican Party should
move away from Donald Trump and I think
that the Democratic party should move
away from Joe Biden but we're stuck with
what we're got so I mean she she has to
be optimistic I mean she has to say
those say those things what is she gonna
say like oh I think my husband you know
I don't think he's going to make it
through four years you know I think he's
going to drop dead after two like I mean
what what is she supposed to what is she
supposed to say um personally I don't
see that Viger and I don't think a lot
of other Americans see that Vigor anyway
I mean that's the thing that a lot of
people say about uh Joe Biden I think I
think a I think a 60 a 65y old Joe Biden
with you know this economy and I'm
putting that in air quotes you know with
this economy doing as well as it is um I
think I I think he probably wins you
know in 2024 but I think the thing that
should scare everybody is when you look
across the aisle and you see a guy
that's got 91 criminal charges he's been
impeached twice he's got four
indictments and you know he he did all
the things I just previously said like
attempted to cool with this country and
you know the rhetoric he uses it's like
how are you losing to that to that guy
like seriously and I think that's when
you see people like David Axelrod and
other people like myself you know uh
ringing the alarm that's what we're
ringing the alarm about it's like yo do
you even want to take the chance of of
of of Joe Biden you know and O over the
next four years do you even want to take
a chance on Joe Biden in this election
that's really the conversation is Joe
Biden and KLA Harris still a winnable
ticket I think Republicans should be
asking themselves that too is is is is
Donald Trump still a winnable ticket I
mean I know the polls say right now he
he he he he'd beat up you know Joe Biden
in in a general election but I don't
know I really I really truly don't know
so to answer your question uh no he
doesn't look full of vigor like his wife
says not to me
anyway